I have a very important question for all
my Muslim friends out there in the Quran
Allah seems to know an awful lot about
the children of Israel oh children of
Israel remember my favor wherewith I
favored you oh children of Israel
remember my favor wherewith I favored
you and how I preferred you to All
Creatures children of Israel children of
Israel children of Israel children of
Israel and I will make him Issa Jesus a
messenger to the children of Israel
children of Israel children of Israel
children of Israel and this verse is
interesting because Allah quotes the
talmud mishna Sanhedrin as a revelation
from him children of Israel children of
Israel children of Israel children of
Israel and we verily did a lot unto the
children of Israel a fixed Abode we gave
unto Moses the scripture and we
appointed it a guidance for the children
of Israel children of Israel children of
Israel children of Israel children of
Israel children of Israel we verily gave
Moses the scripture so be not ye in
doubt of his receiving it and we
appointed it a guidance for the children
of Israel and we verily gave Moses the
the guidance and we caused the children
of Israel to inherit the scripture
children of Israel children of Israel
and verily we gave the children of
Israel the scripture and the command and
the prophethood and provided them with
good things and favored them Above All
Peoples children of Israel children of
Israel children of
Israel Allah has all kinds of things to
say about the children of Israel both
positive and negative sometimes
extremely negative he talks about the
children of Israel over and over again
like a beating
drum now for my question we have dozens
of Quran verses about the children of
Israel where oh where does the Quran
talk about the children of
Palestine chapter and verse
where
exactly no way
not a single verse not a single mention
not a peep about the children of
Palestine why is it all about the
children of Israel why doesn't Allah so
much as acknowledge the children of
Palestine or Palestinians or Palestine
even once not a single solitary shout
out if I Didn't Know Better which I
don't I might think that Allah never
mentions the Palestinians because the
Palestinians as an ethnic group hadn't
been invented yet and spoiler alert the
Palestinians as an ethnic group didn't
exist until more than 3,000 years after
the children of Israel conquered the
Holy Land from the river to the
Sea Allah in the Quran has no clue that
the children of Palestine the children
of Palestine the Palestinians existed at
all because they didn't hadn't been
invented yet in fact you'll only find
Palestine mentioned as a place in the
Quran if you go to a modern Quran
translation like the helli Khan
translation which adds Palestine as
commentary in parenthesis in verses like
Surah 5 verse
21 oh my people enter the Holy Land
Palestine not in the Arabic which Allah
has assigned to you and turn not back in
flight for then you will be returned as
losers so which people are commanded by
Allah to enter Palestine and conquer the
land is he talking to all the
Palestinians who wouldn't exist for
another 3,000 plus years let's read the
context and find out and remember when
mosa Moses said to his people I.E the
children of Israel oh my people remember
the favor of Allah to you when he made
prophets among you made you Kings and
gave you what he had not given to any
other among the alamine Mankind and Jin
in the past oh my people enter the Holy
Land Palestine not in the Arabic which
Allah has assigned to you and turn not
back in flight for then you will be
returned as losers they said oh Musa
Moses in it this Holy Land are a people
of great strength and we shall never
enter it till they leave it when they
leave then we will enter two men of
those who feared Allah and on whom Allah
had bestowed his grace they were yusha
and calb Joshua and Caleb said assault
them through the gate for when you are
in Victory will be yours and put your
trust in Allah if you are believers
indeed the passage continues but this is
part of the story of the children of
Israel escaping captivity in Egypt and
conquering the land of Canaan AKA The
Holy Land AKA what the Pagan Romans
eventually called
Palestine now which people were in the
land that would eventually be called
Palestine before the children of Israel
conquered it who were the people who
were conquered by the children of Israel
the Canaanites the most Pagan of all
pagans the children of Israel conquered
the Canaanites
you've got two options here my Muslim
friends get ready to pick one you can
either say that the Canaanites were the
Palestinians in which case Allah ordered
the children of Israel to conquer them
or you can say that the Palestinians
came later in which case the children of
Israel were there long before the
Palestinians so either the Palestinians
were there first because they were the
Canaanites but Allah wanted them
conquered by the children of Israel or
the Palestinians came later take your
pick but either option completely
destroys the stupid insane propaganda
that I hear 487 times a
day the propaganda that I hear every
single day is that the Palestinians were
always there until the Jews showed up in
the 20th century so the land should be
given back to its rightful owners the
Palestinians on a side note I totally re
reject the ridiculous claim that if one
group was on a piece of land before
another group you have to give the land
back to the earlier group and you reject
it too my Muslim friends if you really
believed that land has to be given back
to people who had it at some earlier
stage you'd be giving back 49 Muslim
countries to the people who were there
before Islam tried to conquer the world
you'd be giving back Mecca because if it
was conquered you'd be giving back
Constantinople because it was conquered
and you would definitely be giving back
the Temple Mount behind
me but you'll never give back anything
because you don't really believe in this
moral principle you made up why do you
pretend to believe a rule that you made
up when you obviously don't believe
it let's face it the reason is that some
of you really hate Jews and you'll say
absolutely anything no matter how false
no matter how insane no matter how
ridiculous no matter how hypocritical as
long as it helps you manipulate morons
into supporting your plans to wipe out
Jews the most amazing part to me here is
that you'll even contradict your own God
and your own Prophet for your political
agenda your God and your Prophet say
that the children of Israel conquered
that land you say no Allah and Muhammad
are lying the Palestinians were there
and then the Jews came and stole the
land from them in the 20th
century to all you Muslims out there who
keep babbling about the Palestinians
being The Originals congratulations
you're apostates now you reject what
Allah says in the Quran because you
don't worship Allah you worship a
political
agenda a Muslim is someone who submits
to what Allah and Muhammad
say you don't submit to what Allah and
Muhammad say you submit to Hamas and
social media jihadis and neo-nazis and
whatever brainwashed college group
you're in and that not according to me
according to your God and your Prophet
is the unforgivable sin of
Sherk as for your thoroughly idolatrous
Pagan political agenda do everyone a
favor and just stop listen to the song
You Can't Always Get What You Want by
The Rolling Stones on repeat until the
message finally sinks in you're not
getting Israel it's not happening not
today not tomorrow not during Ramadan
not for Christmas definitely not for
Hanukkah not on a boat not with a goat
not in a house not with a mouse
take the L and do something constructive
with your
lives might I suggest using some of that
high octane protest energy of yours to
call on Hamas to release the hostages
and surrender
[Music]